hey what's going on as Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday January 1st 2018 oh my god it's a
new year and with the new year comes
hopes and dreams for a better world and
God wants us to sit there and try to
make it a better world well you should
probably start with yourself friends
have you seen those people late night
trying to tell you how to make it a
better world you know somebody writes a
song about it
make it a better place for you and for
me down the street right it's very
difficult the older you get to listen to
those songs going like all right
so not only are you not gonna make the
world a better place
you're gonna write some cheeseball
[ __ ] song and make money off the fact
that people want to make it a better
place
you're gonna give some [ __ ] stupid
pop culture psychology right pop
psychology so what you're gonna throw I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is it's like
after 9/11 when that country guy wrote
that song you know Uncle Sam's go to
boot a boot and you're right it's like
how did he like like that wasn't gonna
be a giant hit you know I don't know
what I'm talking about all I could tell
you is that doing this Monday morning
podcast on Tuesday because I was like
well what do i do do I do it do I do it
the night before I go to the Rose Bowl
and then by the time I tell you the Rose
Bowl stories it's like four days old or
do I just go to the Rose Bowl and do it
a little late I decided on the latter
all right and I apologize to any I don't
know whatever [ __ ] group you know
what I'm hoping in 2018 happens I just
hope that people start standing up to
all of this [ __ ] you know
the amount of people being offended you
know it's not that you get offended it's
the level of coverage that it gets
compared to [ __ ] that really is way way
way more devastating to our lives by the
way you know what really was bugging me
you know when there was all those
hurricanes and everybody everybody
scented [ __ ] money out and all of
that [ __ ] right you got to help all
these people in Houston got to help all
these people in Florida hey where the
[ __ ] were you guys when the Hollywood
Hills were on fire huh I didn't see any
[ __ ] benefits poor [ __ ] uh what's
his name Ralph Nader what's the [ __ ]
guy's name who owns Fox whatever the
[ __ ] his name is well that poor bastards
mansion was catching on fire did any of
you [ __ ] people floating on a
mattress at Houston a few months ago rub
a couple of nickels together and send it
to him make some teary-eyed videos that
just kind of seems like it's a one-way
street here the [ __ ] is the guy's name
alone Spock's isn't Ralph it's one of
those [ __ ] names well he's like you
know you know chicks didn't take him
seriously in high school and then all of
a sudden he owns like the biggest
Network ever and all those women are I
should have [ __ ] Ralph why did I have
to [ __ ] to quarterback Baker me at
[ __ ] Mansfield whatever the [ __ ] his
name is a guy won the Heisman the hell's
his name Baker Mayfield boom boom boom
boom bleep with being sorry that was my
bad Curtis Mayfield what a puller pastor
that guy was huh he's [ __ ] singing
all these great songs he's doing a
goddamn gig and that literally the
lighting falls down on him and breaks
his [ __ ] neck I mean how did he
continue to write music I don't know how
the [ __ ] some people I don't know
I hate to say this I know this about
myself if that ever [ __ ] happened to
me I would just be yelling kill me to
everybody who came walking into the room
we're gonna start your rehab kill me
kill me give me a [ __ ] something I'm
not strong enough to get through this
Jesus this is dark sorry whatever that's
what happens when you just [ __ ] start
running your Yap all of a sudden this
happens okay so I'd like to apologize to
all Curtis Mayfield fans and anybody
stubbed their toe speaking of which I'm
at the [ __ ] I could I cooked up a
goddamn storm this weekend I went out
strong all right so the great J law had
rose bowl tailgate legend
Jason law had he [ __ ] he goes to put
together the menu right any that's
doesn't go we're doing burgers we're
doing dogs he just so he doesn't do that
horse [ __ ] J [ __ ] analyzed like Bill
Belichick he [ __ ] looks okay
Oklahoma's playing George is playing so
next thing you know he's like well in
Oklahoma you know they do this tri-tip
something or other so he gets that going
I tell them hey you want me make a pie
this year he goes yeah once you make a
peach pie for Georgia and he ties this
whole [ __ ] Oklahoma Georgia thing
together it was incredible so I've never
made a peach pie right and I know
peaches are out of season so I'm like
well I'm not gonna go down there and buy
some [ __ ] out of season peach that
some poor [ __ ] bastard had to pick
off of what used to be his own property
down to Costa Rica whatever the [ __ ]
they do however they do the fruit
nowadays I [ __ ] I said I said I'm
gonna get some goddamn canned peaches so
I got some canned peaches picked a
[ __ ] recipe off the internet and this
is what I found with recipes on the
Internet okay they're gonna get it to
you so it tastes really good but they're
not gonna they're not gonna give you the
recipe where it tastes great
so what they're gonna do is they're
gonna you know remember that guy I'm
gonna bring it up
not bad and he'd be screaming and
yelling he had that [ __ ] band emeril
lagasse
right my bio used to take it up a notch
know what they doing the Internet is
every [ __ ] recipe they take it down a
notch they take it down a notch and then
they [ __ ] remove something they take
something out some little special
special spice so anytime you're making a
[ __ ] pie here's a little sage advice
for you alright it's gonna be the usual
okay if you're doing some sort of fruit
there it's gonna be basically a quarter
cup of sugar
I mean quarter cup of flour and like a
cup of sugar and then there's gonna be
cinnamon nutmeg possibly vanilla I don't
know some sort of [ __ ] I think I'm
seeing a t28 and legging teaspoon or
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] that all right they
say eighth of a teaspoon take a nice
helping of it with the eighth of the
teaspoon that's what I do i bam throw
that [ __ ] in there what do you want a
teaspoon I'll give you a teaspoon and a
quarter maybe a teaspoon and a half if
I'm feeling crazy right you just kind of
bring the levels up on everything then
you think what else would they have in
there you know they probably you know
squeeze a little lime on the peaches you
know before they [ __ ] do all of this
[ __ ]
right maybe a little vanilla in there
and then you always got a throw like you
know a little bit of butter in there to
mix all of that [ __ ] together then you
taste it you throw a little more sugar
on top you bring everything up that's
what I did and I got to tell you Matt
got rave reviews on a peach pie who know
who knew you know people you know if you
don't try to explore the limits of your
talents you'll never truly find out how
great your life could be so I made a
peach pie I made a practice one with Nia
and it was a deal I didn't have a lot of
time so I actually went to the store and
bought a store-bought frozen pie on the
bottom sacrilegious and then I made a
homemade 1/4 on top you know cut my work
in half and then there was just all this
weirdness where the one in the bottom
kind of done but the one on top wasn't
so I took it out and uh you know Nia
took one bite of it just goes does that
[ __ ] and I knew she was right but I also
got mad at her you know what I mean
because I'm lazy I didn't want to go
back so I [ __ ] egg wash the goddamn
pie because I forgot to do that sprinkle
some sugar on it threw it back in then
it was better and I made a decent pie
but then I brought all the levels up and
the one that I did to the Rose Bowl
[ __ ] crushed or maybe people were
just being nice
I don't know I also made a quiche
Lorraine I've always wanted to make a
quiche I mean who doesn't like eggs who
doesn't like pie I mean right there you
got both things going on this is
breakfast and dessert all at the same
[ __ ] time and I go to make this thing
and of course knee is all over me
looking at this looking at that looking
at this I [ __ ] stick the quiche in
there all right do the whole damn thing
I [ __ ] 45 minutes in you know I give
it a little poke with the tongs it still
looks jello II as hell so I leave it in
for another 10 minutes then it looks
pretty much solid and I'm getting
nervous that I'm gonna burn it so I take
it out I let it cool off a couple of
hours later I cut into it it looks a
little runny but I'm too hungry so I
don't give a [ __ ] so I'm eating it it's
clearly needs to go back in the oven for
10 minutes but it's [ __ ] delicious so
I go Nia try this I think it needs to be
you know I think it needs to go back in
the oven maybe for 10 minutes and she
just cuts in and she goes move and then
eats and goes and I just went you know
what [ __ ] you and she's like what I'm
just being honest I'm like I know I know
I just want it but it still tastes good
right she goes yeah but it's runny as
[ __ ] needs to go back in the oven I'm
like we could have said it tasted good
first did she stormed out of the room
and then I was like oh come on I won't
be like this in 2018 so I put it back in
the oven for like another 10 minutes
actually Nia did she finish the thing
off and it uh it tastes it [ __ ]
delicious and then before the [ __ ]
rose
bull the night before I'm thinking
alright lawhead is gonna be making his
classic [ __ ] breakfast sandwich which
is basically a English muffin he puts a
little Havarti cheese on one side and
then he has his avocado spread he does
on the other side then he cooks this
[ __ ] egg to absolute perfection where
it's not too runny it's not over hard
it's just perfect not quite over me
medium it's only like a medium rare so
when you bite into it the egg yolk uses
out but it doesn't fall out of the
sandwich and all of that [ __ ] right and
then also he he had marinated this this
tri-tip that he put on top of that and
it was the best [ __ ] eggs it was such
a good egg sandwich I only had one
because he goes you want to have another
one it's like no I don't want to kill it
you know what I mean and the night
before I had made these hash browns you
know the thing about it is you don't
want to make the [ __ ] things but she
also don't want the things to turn all
brown and [ __ ] so I actually did the
whole mix and then put it in a [ __ ]
ziplock bag and squished all the air out
of it I possibly could stuck it in the
fridge and it was fine
I cooked those [ __ ] up on the side at
that point I was a little shit-faced I
think I overdid it that's right I was
already drunk before breakfast even came
out all right
we had already loaded up the truck we
put the game changer in there the game
changer who by the way all right the
game changer is a flattop griddle with
four burners all right and the propane
gas I'm telling you right that's what
the [ __ ] you want to bring to a cookout
that thing it's just you never have to
worry about your fire going out there's
not like there's not all this pressure
there's none of that [ __ ] you just
turned that [ __ ] thing on Jase just
like a short-order cook I've never the
last two years I've never seen him so
relaxed at a cookout because before you
you know we had a hibachi that's way
down here we had another one that was up
on its legs this guy's going he's doing
like [ __ ] 400 squats an hour trying
to cook everything making sure his fire
doesn't go out time and [ __ ] and and he
cooks the whole time something he's
cooking one thing he cooks a breakfast
and he cooks something in the middle
then he cooks the dinner so he was
always having to add [ __ ] and coals and
all that means over the course of like
six hours
so the flattop grilled that j-law had
dubbed the game-changer
he was just crushing it all day and I
got in these things because this was our
10th Rose Bowl in a row and anybody
who's married knows that your ten-year
thing is tin and not only do they know
that's that you note in the tin
anniversary you there's no way you can
go out and buy something made out of tin
for your wife only and she's gonna be
happy with that unless you met an
absolute sweetheart who doesn't mind
being broke or it doesn't mind that she
married a cheap [ __ ] one of the other
anyways so I went out and I got these
flasks made up for me and bartnik cuz we
we were the original guys it was just a
to just at two of us the first year so I
got a giant Roman numeral ten like the
Super Bowl
engraved on the front and on the back I
just had Joe bartnik Rose Bowl tailgate
legend and then I did like the American
Express the members since and they had
oh nine and next year law had gets his
and in two years familis gets his
although I have to correct his because I
already had him made up and I thought
that they both came in 2010 anyway so
I'm out there throwing the football
around I got some booze in me right I
smoked a little weed which I never do
but I'm just trying to lay off the booze
and this is why I don't smoke weed is
because you know with booze if you reach
for a bottle of vodka you know okay you
know
basically what the punch to the face is
gonna be or if you grab a beer you know
what that's gonna be you grab some wine
you know what that's gonna be
when someone goes hey you want to take a
hit of this joint you don't know what
the [ __ ] it is is that the is it that
[ __ ] that just kind of makes you feel
like hey man like everything's gonna be
alright man or is it gonna have you just
[ __ ] staring at a goddamn tree so I
you know I don't know what what are you
supposed to do just take one hit and
then stand there and wait for your face
to start melting and be like oh well it
didn't
this is why I'm done with [ __ ] weed
too so I take a [ __ ] hit I don't feel
anything I'm like oh this must be the
light one so then I go back in about two
three times and next thing you know I'm
telling everybody at the tailgate I go
hey man listen I know I'm really high
right now but look at that [ __ ] tree
in that [ __ ] that trees [ __ ] a
mess like some [ __ ] out of a horror
movie look at that look at the way it's
like bent like that
and they just laughing at me and I am so
at peace that I don't care that I'm
actually I don't give a [ __ ] that
they're laughing at me I'm just happy at
that point that I'm bringing them joy as
I make a complete fool of myself and I'm
drinking from the flask and then Jay
throws a burger on we got this grass-fed
[ __ ] this grass-fed [ __ ] meat dude
I [ __ ] it might have been the best
burger I ever had but also I was so high
I was just talking to people about this
[ __ ] tree which felt like an intense
minute so you know it was like at least
probably what like 11 minutes I ate that
burger it was [ __ ] amazing
and then I went over to a chair i sat
down and I passed out for like two hours
Jay was making these [ __ ] meatball
subs on a brioche bun and I completely
at the last like four or five years in
in a row I have missed the main course
and by the way Americans call it anime
call it a main
course don't call it the entree all
right in French entre means to enter it
that's actually the beginning of the
meal and somewhere across the [ __ ]
ocean in the scurvy and the [ __ ]
slavery and the indentured servitude
however whatever distracted us we [ __ ]
that up entree means to enter that's the
beginning ok so just say the main course
and for the main course I'll have this
what do you have for entrees so I missed
that I woke up and I ended up I tried
the pie with the ala mode it was [ __ ]
delicious everybody loved it and at that
point I was kind of [ __ ] sober because
I was actually way more high than I was
shit-faced and I didn't even smoke a
cigar and I went into the I went into
the game and I just started any time a
vendor came by I just started crushing
waters I was already on the wagon that's
how [ __ ] up I got at the tailgate like
you know you know like when you're still
legally drunk in you're already back on
the what you're telling people I'm on
the wagon and you have like literally
they could like your breath on fire you
know you went too hard I don't really
have any [ __ ] stories about the
tailgate cause I barely remember it
other than it was [ __ ] awesome I do
remember I was drinking Millers I was
drinking out of that flask I had you
know once a year mill I had Miller and
Miller Lite Miller Lite comes back with
their old-school less filling tastes
great bottle so I had a couple of those
I threw the football around lefty I
vaguely remember that oh and then
somebody the tailgate told me a [ __ ]
story about how Garoppolo ended up on
the [ __ ] 49ers evidently the
Cleveland Browns were interested in
getting him but Bill Belichick still
holds a grudge against them for
for his time you know 1995 when he was
coaching it which I believe he was also
with [ __ ] what's-his-face Nick Savin
there so he's like [ __ ] at and he
calls up the 49ers he goes give me a
second round draft pick will give you
Garoppolo how [ __ ] nuts is it I've
heard a couple of those stories recently
like do you know the Celtics got into a
position to get to to get Bill Russell
this is a story that was told to me
sit down gather around and listen to
this tale the Celtics had too good of a
year to be in a position to draft Bill
Russell so read our Beck makes a bunch
of [ __ ] moves to get all the way up
to number two
all right but the problem is is the
Rochester Royals of some [ __ ] number
one there was nothing he could do to get
them to not you know to give up the
number one pick and everybody was gonna
take Bill Russell he was just clearly
the best guy so the boston guy had the
[ __ ] Ice Capades every year and they
used to make a bunch of money off that
now I know a lot of you [ __ ]
Millennials out there like the Ice
Capades bunch of people twirling around
dressed on the ice right skating around
dressed like [ __ ] Yogi and boo-boo
bear why the [ __ ] would I go see that
[ __ ] well it was before the Internet
the one you had a little black and white
[ __ ] TV you know what I mean the
picture was always jump and this was a
some exciting [ __ ] it wasn't a titty bar
or [ __ ] free internet porn every once
in a while you know once a year these
beautiful [ __ ] goddess women would
come in with their shapely thighs and he
could sit there and look at him and
pretend you were into the art you just
sat right next to your wife you could
[ __ ] you know look at some gams over
there right so it would always sell out
so the Rochester Royals were hurting for
money so Red Auerbach called up the ice
capade guy he goes hey can you do me a
[ __ ] solid can you [ __ ] get the
Ice Capades can you guarantee that
you'll do a couple of dates out there
for these [ __ ]
guys he said absolutely I will so he
called them up as it listen I'll give me
the number one pick I'll give you the
[ __ ] Ice Capades for a week you make
all this goddamn money and the miser
that owned the team said you know what
I'll take that deal I will say forget
Bill Russell so Dorothy Hamill can come
in or Peggy Fleming whoever the [ __ ] it
was back there I don't know way back
then was probably some woman named Ethel
and she was considered hot right
Ethel McGuire and Hazel sagorsky her
come and skate oh my god you ever seen
so [ __ ] hot right years later they
wrote on the Golden Girls but back then
they were a hot piece of ass now I know
I skipped over a lot of [ __ ] details
so you should probably listen to the
Bill Simmons podcast right to figure out
what really happened but that's what was
told to me and you know what goddamn it
I'm sticking with it I'm [ __ ]
sticking with that story
so anyways old Billy no fun I'm not
going a bunch of days again but like I'm
just like I'm done all right
I off the wagon on December 26th and now
it's January 2nd and I'm right back on I
had I one day I didn't drink all right
that was the 28th December 20th so six
out of the last seven days I drank I
don't like how I feel I don't like how I
look I just can't [ __ ] do it anymore
okay I'm turning 50 in June I had a
great half of a century run all right I
never really drank until I was like 17
so whatever I had a good 33 years Larry
speaking of the guard I had a nice 33
year run okay so I am now gonna be that
guy that picks his spot am I gonna be
that [ __ ] dude
maybe I'll just be that guy that has a
glass of wine with dinner every once in
a while you know it's just like just all
this awkward silence between me and my
wife as we sit on either end of this
really long dinner table you know you
know you hear it's just me like turning
the pages of the paper and
you know shaking it you know you do that
thing to make sure it straightens out
every once in a while just being like
holy did you see down in Brazil and hit
a ruin I don't know what I'm gonna do
but uh I'm just I'm I'm bringing it the
way I was bringing everything up in that
recipe I'm bringing everything down
bringing everything down all right I'm
[ __ ] back to crush in the waters I'm
back onto my diet and I got a couple of
goals this year all right one of the
biggest mistakes I made in my adult life
was buying 34-inch jeans after being a
32 all right 32 best shape of my [ __ ]
life they started getting a little tight
around the [ __ ] waist and I thought
oh you know you get older you fill out
and it's like no pill you put on weight
you [ __ ] why don't you just take [ __ ]
seven to ten days to lose I didn't I
bought the next size up jeans okay and
that was stupid because that just gave
me this leeway to be a fat [ __ ] who
feels comfortable in his pants you never
buy the next size up jeans after you're
done growing and all of that [ __ ] you
know I mean unless you're a [ __ ]
beanpole which maybe I was so I'm back
down to 33 that figure I'll stay there
so that's what I'm gonna do I got it
like my [ __ ] wardrobe right now I got
it it's just like you know I hate going
shopping all right
and I have not bought a [ __ ] a shirt
or a pair of pants in a couple of years
kind of [ __ ] a couple of free
t-shirts
I bought a primus t-shirt at the concert
I went to but other than that it is just
I just you know and I got rid of a bunch
of old clothes so I have like I have two
shirts that I wear one of two shirts
when I [ __ ] head like those are my
two headlining shirts and I think I have
a pullover sweater and that's it
and I don't think I give a [ __ ] you know
I got to go out there and have some
[ __ ] rhinestones shiny goddamn shirt
I really believe that as long as I have
a [ __ ] act that nobody's gonna be
really paying attention to the shirt
right well now that I brought it up you
gonna I don't know maybe I'll buy shadow
maybe I'll buy a [ __ ] sweater
you know I'm thinking I'm thinking I'm
gonna be that guy that just dresses all
in black if I wasn't so [ __ ] pasty
and I wouldn't look like a floating head
in hands I would do that but what's
great about a black shirt is you could
wear that like three days in a row
before anybody really even notices like
this [ __ ] not changing his
shirt you know that is the genius of
Malcolm young rest his soul the greatest
rhythm guitarist in rock and roll
history in my opinion the genius of the
way that that meant dressed the sheer
amount of money that that man saved by
just wearing jeans and a [ __ ] t-shirt
right Einstein that said Einstein [ __ ]
that's what geniuses do they get rid of
all the white noise and they just focus
on what's [ __ ] important that's what
he did he just was just Alan his pants
and a shirt I'm not gonna be [ __ ]
sitting there trying to be in style I'm
gonna dress timeless blue jeans and a
[ __ ] black t-shirt and I'm done you
ever see the let there be rock video
that's one of my favorite parts of the
video when he's getting ready for this
show and he takes a t-shirt off and then
he snaps his fingers like he's his
spoiled rockstar and they just throw him
another t-shirt the exact same color he
puts it on or a slightly different color
and then that's it it's over
anyways my shoulders been doing great
and then I [ __ ] it up at the at the
the tailgate by the way I was throwing
left handed doing all right you know
making sure I was given my right
shoulder arrest and everything I hadn't
felt any pain in my shoulder for days
long story short at the end of the end
of the tailgate were going to to close
up the table and I'm on one side with
the other guys on the other side and
we're folding up the legs and the one
was getting stubborn and where I had my
fingers it [ __ ] slammed down on both
of my fingers right just wave and I went
ah [ __ ] and I pulled my arms out you
know I was basically reaching around the
[ __ ] table you know like I was given
the skinniest person ever the finish we
had that finishing move in wrestling
well they just put you in a [ __ ] bear
hug and they would act like they were
being crushed to death I was doing that
with the tables so when I went to yank
my arms out really quickly it was like
it was like I was throwing two elbows at
the same time and I felt like [ __ ]
lightning in my right shoulder and I
think I went right back to square one I
don't know what the [ __ ] I got it I
think I'm gonna do that Kobe [ __ ] Rogan
told me about that whole stem-cell [ __ ]
and I just get scared of that stuff I
don't know the way Jill Rogan is
fearless and will read up on something
and then make an informed decision
before he takes his step in that
direction I just hear about something
new do not read up on it and act like an
old lady who thinks the [ __ ] sky is
falling that's the way I approach life
so I haven't done that yet my shoulders
still [ __ ] up I might do that thing
will they take your wrong what I like
about that [ __ ] spinning on your
blood is it your own blood and then they
shoot it back in right although I would
want to watch them the whole time you
know follow them around with my own
blood to make sure they don't take like
the [ __ ] blood of a yak or a [ __ ]
chimp or some [ __ ] whatever they
whatever the [ __ ] they whatever they're
doing these days to try to get that
thing fixed
alright let me let me read to what do I
have any advertising
I don't know that I do during the
holidays it slows down I don't have any
advertising well what do you know what
do you know all right let me see here I
guess I don't have any advertisement
[ __ ] it let's continue talking all right
this is what else I did oh my wonderful
over my wonderful holiday break I went
down to the comedy store did his set had
a great time and I was driving home you
know and driving along sunset I'm just
starting to [ __ ] listen to my tunes
and all of a sudden I go by this venue
and I look and what do I see I see
Dave Chappelle and John Mayer are doing
a show him I get the [ __ ] out of here
right so I call up a buddy of mine that
books all the shows and I said hey
what's what's the story with this just
John Mayer you know come out with his
band you know there's Dave going first
it's John going first of all blond he's
like now what happens is John comes out
plays like four songs he brings Dave out
Dave does stand-up for an hour an hour
and a half and then he brings John back
out and then they just sort of riff as
Dave talks about [ __ ] John will play the
music underneath and I was like I gotta
[ __ ] see that
so me and my mean lovely Nia we went
down there because I never take a route
on New Year's Eve because that is the
original st. Patrick's Day plus I go to
the Rose Bowl the next day so I need to
get my sleep before I get absolutely
hammered and passed out a [ __ ] chair
for a couple hours
missing my meatball sub so we went down
there and just had the such a great
[ __ ] night and I don't think I've
ever seen that I don't think I've seen
two people that [ __ ] talented like
this usually one genius and then
surrounded by a bunch of people who are
just sitting there isn't he amazing I'm
so happy to be Bennett playing bass with
this genius or I'm so happy to be
[ __ ] I don't know whatever the [ __ ]
else
I'm so happy being the Ice Capades with
this twirling genius right it was two of
them and what I kind of notice about
both of them is that they just so like
most genius minds think they kind of
they get rid of all the [ __ ] white
noise everything about every bit that
Chappelle did was just like there was no
fat on it
and he got right to the [ __ ] point
another thing that I loved was I can't
believe that I've been in this business
long enough that we're like the older
guys now and it always blows my mind
that I'm like five years older than Dave
Chappelle because he was already a made
guy when I came in so I always look at
him like he's got ten years on me you
know or 15 it's you know just when I
watch his act I'm like this guy's
clearly been doing this a good couple of
decades longer than me and the reality
is I think he's only been doing it like
six years longer than I have or
something like that
he's [ __ ] amazing and what I love too
is just he's that same with all that's
changed everybody getting offended all
of this [ __ ] crap by you get in
trouble he hasn't changed at all he's
just like that same guy that I saw way
back in the day when I used to go to the
Boston comedy club and watch him go on
it like 2:00 in the morning
and just start murdering at 2:00 in the
[ __ ] morning
and I remember he's always sit there
going on uh how do you do that how you
get that funny at 2:00 in the morning in
front of a crowd that gave up on the
show like an hour ago and they're tired
they just want to go home that second he
steps on stage boom he just like he just
starts [ __ ] killing so you know
Dave's up there murdering me and the
like just [ __ ] laughing die and
having a great time and and then he
brings John Mayer back on I don't want
to ruin the show for him because I don't
know how many they're gonna do but uh
basically if Dave was up there and he
was just saying like you know I was
watching [ __ ] Hawaii five-o like John
whatever
she [ __ ] riffs and clearly that Dave
is just ripping like Mayer could play
whatever the [ __ ] he said and Dave said
that at one point he goes I don't know
if you guys realize this [ __ ] but John
Mayer can play whatever he hears and
then he just started doing all this
crazy [ __ ] like making his guitar sound
like a cat or a car beeping like it went
beyond I could play songs like he can
just do noises around the house but it
was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] incredible so
if you get a chance I don't know you
know if you get a chance to go see the
show definitely definitely go do it
alright and with that let me speaking of
which let me promote this the Patrice
O'Neal comedy benefit I forgot to
[ __ ] ask Dave Chappelle if he ever
wanted to come in and do it
god dammit
anyways alright Patrice O'Neal benefit
is on February 20th 2018 it makes a
great gift for Christmas this is old
copy whatever it's a great [ __ ]
benefit we have all these amazing
comedians on it and what a great way to
start the year by seeing an all-star
lineup of old comedians like myself all
the way down to new comedians that were
influenced by Patrice O'Neal by the way
I'm gonna post this video once a year I
gotta post it is that one when when
Patrice was watching the up-and-down
game just his laugh and all of that [ __ ]
I just got a once-a-year I I kind of
watched that video once a year and it's
kind of been nice over the years where
it became less sad for me to watch it
and now it just you know I got it I
guess I got to the point in my grief
which I'll never be over him not being
around but I guess I've gotten to the
point with my grief where I just I just
think like like what an amazing person
to have known
I see it's still sad it's it's always
gonna be sad what can you do
it's gonna be [ __ ] set so I'll post
that but those you new to the podcast
you know Missy years go by maybe even
new to Patrice which blows my mind but
uh I'll post that video and then you can
go down a wonderful hilarious rabbit
hole of anything that [ __ ] guy ever
said so anyways we're doing a benefit
for his loved ones that he was taking
care of when he was still alive and all
the money after we get done paying for
the [ __ ] venue being upfront being
transparent we'll go to his love once
all right it's on February 20th in New
York City what a great excuse to go to
New York City go skating down
Rockefeller Center watch a bunch of
great comedians honor the greatest comic
that I ever saw Patrice O'Neal February
20th 2018 at the New York City Center
all right there we go
moving on did anybody watch the Celtics
versus the Houston [ __ ] Rockets holy
[ __ ]
goddamn what a [ __ ] game that was
James Harden by the ways is fun to
[ __ ] watch you know I love about tech
guy he looks he doesn't look like a
basketball player I look at that guy and
I go that guy knows how to play the
trumpet there's something about it
doesn't he looks like one of those
[ __ ] like his last name should be
Hargrove or some [ __ ] and this I don't
know somebody shorts his beard and his
haircut it's very he looks ABA ish even
though I guess he should have a giant
afro I don't know what but I taped the
game I heard how amazing once I already
knew the result and I watched the game
and of course my [ __ ] my my recording
cut off right at the end of the game
before Al Horford hit the shot and in a
harden kind of had a meltdown I guess
through stuff Marcus smart to the floor
some [ __ ] I don't know what happened but
I guess he got pissed he went a little
Gronkowski against the bills by the way
congratulations to the Buffalo Bills I
was actually really pulling for you guys
even though you're in our division or
whatever I just feel like the football
gods have punished you guys enough it
was great to see you guys back get back
in with Tyrod Taylor so congratulations
on that and then also can you believe
the [ __ ] NFL season is already over
how does that happen I'll tell you what
else I don't understand how it happens
is I go to see that unbelievable Rose
Bowl game I just [ __ ] saw and I
didn't even talk about the game alright
here's my breakdown of the game [ __ ]
[ __ ] here we go you know this is
gonna be an intelligence breakdown in
the game Oklahoma's going no-huddle the
whole [ __ ] first half Georgia's
goddamn head is spinning around they
don't know what to do right before the
half they kick an onside kick which I
get this six seconds left you're
thinking alright I don't want this guy
to run this ball back we'll kick it to
an up person they will [ __ ] tackle
them yadda yadda yadda and that will be
over who the [ __ ] knew Georgia was gonna
come out throw a quick [ __ ] pass get
in field goal range and instead of being
down by three scores 17 points they're
only down by two scores well like dumb
[ __ ] move and Georgia's get in the
goddamn ball
alright no no I'm sorry Oklahoma I got
the ball they kicked off to him that was
the thing you know up by 17 [ __ ]
points and they were getting the ball
after the half I mean they had their
foot on their [ __ ] neck I get the
onside thing I don't fault him for that
but in the third quarter when they stop
going no-huddle they started playing
marty ball and they're trying to bleed
out the [ __ ] clock I actually get
that [ __ ] move but then Georgia
scores to touchdown now they've scored
10 unanswered you're still trying to
bleed the clock they score another
touchdown now they've gone 17 unanswered
you're still in your huddle they score
24 [ __ ] unanswered points to go up by
seven before you finally decide
to go back to no-huddle in the second
they go back to no-huddle Georgia has a
problem again BAM they scored a [ __ ]
touchdown I'm running out of sound
effects kazowie
they fumble the ball you return it now
you're up by [ __ ] seven you just got
to give it to Georgia Bulldogs named
Georgia goddamn [ __ ] Bulldogs they
came back tied it up and for the first
time in a hundred and I don't know how
many goddamn years of the [ __ ] Rose
Bowl alright they had an overtime game
and it doesn't just go to one over time
it goes to two two overtimes
congratulations to the Georgia Bulldogs
on an amazing victory I don't know why I
was but I was actually gonna even though
I'm a big SEC guy I was kind of torn I
was a little emotionally torn I was
rooting for Oklahoma for whatever
[ __ ] reason I just decided I was
gonna root for them I don't have
anything against Georgia but I was I was
actually also on another level kind of
psyched to see Georgia win because j-law
head is so [ __ ] pissed that Ohio
State didn't get in and he thinks the
SEC is totally [ __ ] overrated and you
know he was arguing for the pac-12 he
was at one point he was [ __ ] arguing I
was like Jesus Christ J it's eight
o'clock you're already [ __ ] whining it
by the Buckeyes and he said the most
innocent voice every point it at
somebody else at the tailgate he goes he
brought it up he burned it he went from
like going and we uh we [ __ ] bug
repellents he brought it up so I thought
it was kind of funny you know and then
Alabama also once so both SEC teams SEC
teams that got in are now gonna play for
the championship so the SEC is gonna win
another [ __ ] title and it just cracks
me up that that's gonna bug j-law head
and he just will not admit that on the
ohio state buckeyes had no [ __ ]
business last year of being one of the
Final Four
considering they lost a Penn State and
then Penn State won the title he goes
bill you're not listening what I'm
saying I'm saying that Penn State got
screwed I did but that's all he'll say
he will not say that Ohio State did not
deserve to be in there last year despite
the fact that they then went there and
lost 24/7 and he's all [ __ ] deshaun
Watson was [ __ ] unbelievable it's like
dude he wasn't you scored no points so I
feel like Ohio State this year got
punished for the [ __ ] snooze fest
they basically ate their balls last year
and wanted to get another Saturday night
8 o'clock spot at the club they're like
nobody you're gonna get a Wednesday and
I actually think that Ohio State would
have done great you know considering
when I watched their game how their
front four are all first and
second-round draft picks on the
defensive side I actually agree with
Jayla head but like you don't get your
cake and eat it you don't get to suck
and get in and lose by 24 points and
don't even score one [ __ ] point the
year before and then the next year when
you're actually good enough to get and
also get rewarded you know so that's my
beef that's my beef with jail ahead but
I still love the guy to death so we'll
get over it
anyways amazing [ __ ] game and we we
went the whole game without having an
incident until the very end I don't know
what happened bartnik was you know a
little boost up and I think he bumped
into somebody in front of us in this
[ __ ] guy who I swear to god was as
old as me starts yelling at bartnik and
bartnik is just staring at him and I'm
just staring at him and he's like I'm
being nice stop up and we just [ __ ]
stare at him I'm looking at this guy
like dude you're as old as me and you're
yelling at the human version of a
[ __ ] Kodiak bear and the guy didn't
know what he was waiting for us to
respond and we didn't respond me was
just law had we were all just staring at
the guy and they just looks at Joey goes
talk to
they [ __ ] turrets around it's like
dude between all of us were about 225
years old this is the first Rose Bowl
ever that is going into [ __ ] overtime
you want you want to get kicked out you
want to roll around on these stadium
floors with you [ __ ] this guy wasn't
even wearing true religion jeans
whatsapp it become dad James in the last
[ __ ] 12 years he's he went I think he
was he was probably wearing that you
know the lead jeans and on the tag it
just said in giant bold letters Lee you
know which where I came from basically
meant it you know your family was barely
could barely afford to live in a
blue-collar town if he had the Lee jeans
the Lee jeans and the Gap jeans you know
you had to have Levi's yeah I believe
that's how simple life was back then if
you had Levi's that meant that your
parents were actually doing well okay
and it before diesel jeans came in and
[ __ ] it just [ __ ] it all up
you know jeans were like 25 30 bucks and
I know with inflation will just say
jeans for like 50 bucks right then all
of a sudden diesel comes along and then
like twice that and the next thing you
know that's like $200 pairs of jeans
that suffocate your balls and still
can't get up and over your flat ass I
don't [ __ ] understand what I don't
understand jeans and then that tapered
in down the bottom like you're gonna do
ballet and people need to see your feet
right like you're gonna reenact the
Thriller video I don't know anyways
let's read some of the [ __ ] the
letters here over the that I got if I
can find him oh I guess I didn't copy
and paste them did I where are they
alright here we go this is a very
dramatic email it's it
the name of this email is goodbye dear
bill I'm sadly no longer a fan it's
really too bad because I was a huge fan
all right what do you think I did what
did I say who did I say it about went to
see you and Paul virzi in Albany New
York oh that was a great show when I
have watched every one of your specials
as well as f is for family and I'm an
avid podcast listener all right so what
he's doing now he or she is doing is
establishing that they listen to every
[ __ ] thing that I do this is what
everybody does when they complain you
can't just complain you have to
establish credibility like when people
argue politics you know they sit there
and they go hey I'm a Democrat I'm for
gay marriage of pre legalizing the pot
but dis Obama has gone too far
all right nor the other way around you
know I'm [ __ ] blah blah blah but this
Trump this is what everybody does all
right he goes I'm not super religious Oh
Jay Jay you're not super religious but I
obviously said something about your God
all right but you took it too far when
you trashed Jesus and anyone who
believes in them the [ __ ] did I do that
dude do you understand that this is
unscripted I don't remember half the
[ __ ] I said today I mean if you want to
take it seriously by all means because
you take your shots here and there which
is tolerable but in the 12 28 17 of the
podcast it was just too much well I
gotta listen to that one I didn't hear
it the first time and I wish whomever is
picking the replays had more of an
inkling than to play that expert excerpt
as much as I wish you didn't say well
aren't you glad that they played it so
now you can know how bad a person I am
this probably won't matter to you
because at this point you don't need me
anymore
come back in the into the comedy Hut
that being said I've been a big promoter
and a supporter for a long time this has
to be a woman this that just doin dick
just going 100% guilt I'm sure you will
never read this as you probably have a
screener at this point just taking a
shot I do wish you continued success ah
look at this and they're still gonna go
out as a class this person's a class act
and nothing but the best for you and the
lovely Mia
it's Nia with an N you know what I'm
saying goodbye to you the amount of
times that I said Nia on the podcast and
you still don't even know my wife's name
and you have the nerve to get upset with
me because I trash the old J star there
why don't ya what would Jesus do Jesus
would forgive me and continue to listen
to the podcast wouldn t I would think
anyways
that being said up being a Bubba for the
lovely Mia and your daughter in there
Boston sucks and go [ __ ] yourself PS
check out Garry Newman's new album all
synth but really cool alright PSS if you
don't read this well if you do read this
don't use a southern accent because I'm
from New York lol you know what but
you're gonna be back I I got a feeling
you're gonna be back I love these
[ __ ] people that it's just like all
the dumb [ __ ] that I say I've trashed
people that smoke weed I trash women I
trash Jesus I trash [ __ ] anybody
who's a Republican anybody who's a
Democrat all of this [ __ ] [ __ ] and
everybody listens and listens and
listens and all of a sudden once it you
know [ __ ] comes into your world like
Ida trash above-ground pools and all of
a sudden I gotta listen to somebody
going right you know just because I
can't afford to take a goddamn hole in
my backyard you know look at that right
there
offensive to southern people as if
there's people up north that can't
afford to [ __ ] have a backhoe
come in there and whatever the [ __ ] it
is that they do right dig into the
goddamn ground hey you know what I mean
all right so you draw the line at Jesus
well there you go I mean as far as my
limited understanding of Jesus and what
exactly it was he was trying to prove
with all his party tricks with the fish
and the bread over there I think he was
a very forgiving person sir so I think
if you're truly into the teachings of
Jesus and you're truly strong enough
spiritually you can handle 120-minute
[ __ ] clip from a goddamn podcast from
a few [ __ ] years ago you know what
the real thing is here sir is you need
to grow up okay what I am saying is not
gonna infiltrate into your [ __ ] soul
and all of a sudden make you possess and
have you kill your whole family
why can't you just look at me and feel
sad for me that I'm gonna go to hell and
that you're gonna go to heaven you're
gonna be in a little puffy cloud there
is I'm burning forever right why don't
you just look at it that way all right
it's not that he's leaving it's that you
know all the dumb [ __ ] that I say all of
the dumb [ __ ] that I [ __ ] say and
then it's that one thing you look past
everything else all right
but whatever you know more power to you
god bless you god bless you in your
search I wish you well on your search to
a Jesus only positivity podcast all
right all right your journey to a a bear
dear Billy to shift drinking albino
ginge dad bod once a solid seat cup now
is solid a cup sir moves a lot there's a
muffle all right me and another friend
of Bill W agree that your qualifying
story for AAA is unfolding perfectly all
right here we go I'm an alcoholic so you
must be an alcoholic all right I'm gonna
lose this guy's event I hate [ __ ] AAA
people there's nothing more
self-involved
than someone who is an addictive
personality and all they think is
whatever happened to them
whatever they're going through you also
have to be going through because they
are the center of the [ __ ] universe
all right from your off the wagon on the
wagon off the wagon to your let's try
some control drinking you are perfect
AAA material can't wait to hear about
your surrender and your acknowledgement
that you lack and that lack of power is
your dilemma no Jesus Christ it's not
projecting all of your [ __ ] you [ __ ]
loser
I [ __ ] hate people in AAA I really do
not all of them but people like this
listen dude just because you were under
the sink during your kid's birthday
drinking [ __ ] mouthwash don't break
my balls over I don't have to go to your
dumbass [ __ ] meeting I've gone to
some AAA meetings dude the stories you
guys tell my jaw is on the [ __ ]
ground
you guys make me look like a [ __ ]
fairy he's in denial right now the gang
a gang but dude I'm gonna tell you
something that I just did I just went
off the wagon for six days drank like an
animal yesterday and while I was drunk
effortlessly said you know and I'm not
drinking anymore effortlessly I didn't
have to surrender and say I have no
power over there's a better better bet I
don't need to go down to your dumbass
group and smoke cigarettes and eat
doughnuts with all you guys down there
with you blown out [ __ ] wallflower
noses alright I'm fine anyways and your
discovery that there is a Power greater
than yourself one who can solve all your
problems
yeah or one that you can dump all your
[ __ ] on it's a great life you could even
even say it's a life second to none one
day at a time
easy does it keep it simple stupid I
just can't wait to hear you speak from
the podium delivering a message of hope
it's not the meetings
make it's the steps you take thankfully
there are only 12 of them love your
biggest 32 year old blonde Nigerian fan
hey god bless you and your sobriety but
no all right whatever
this is how my sobriety works I just
like how I feel when I'm sober from a
toll I like how I look I like the weight
that I become its total vanity and there
becomes a point in your life where you
just get just too [ __ ] old to drink
it just beats the [ __ ] out of you
so thank you sir but I don't need to go
down there and surrender and you know
I'm telling you right now if you think
you're a [ __ ] alcoholic go to a
goddamn a a meeting these [ __ ] people
I swear to god they'll tell stories were
like like they're sitting there half
that nose is hanging off their face and
they're just going like so I take some
duct tape and I [ __ ] tape my nose
back onto my face and all I'm thinking
is I gotta go back to the liquor store
and get more booze man when I got
arrested for drinking and driving about
thirty [ __ ] years ago I remember I
was required to go to two AAA meetings
and I was like these people are out of
their [ __ ] and every story was that
they would do and then I belted my wife
in the face I actually hit my wife over
the head with our own child and the
crazy thing is is I was thinking like
you know what I got to go get a drink I
[Music]
know look I shouldn't be laughing at
people that have that much of a [ __ ]
problem okay but I can tell you this sir
I don't need to surrender to anything
all right
I know that I there are times in my life
when I drink too much and I have the
ability to look at myself say I have a
problem and then [ __ ] walk away from
it that's it
all right and I want to tell you I want
you to answer me name one of your
[ __ ] AEA friends down there
that can come off the wagon and drank
like I did you know yesterday I drank
six out of seven days they had two
drinks one day I had a beer the next day
didn't drink the next day had two drinks
at the John Mayer Chappell thing and
then had two drinks the next day and
then [ __ ] got hammered at at the Rose
Bowl and now I can just feel like I'd
[ __ ] that I'm not doing that now that's
it I can I can do that sir I'm sorry
that you can't do that I'm sorry that
you need to go down there and put your
arms around a budget well they got to
give you a little chip every little
here's your little [ __ ] cookie you
know god bless you
how many [ __ ] people might lose it on
this podcast god bless you buddy if
that's what the [ __ ] you have to do are
you one of those alcoholics to who's
still a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and then
blames everything on your [ __ ]
disease oh sorry bro it's just gonna let
a [ __ ] coming up you know you got that
built-in [ __ ] excuse anyways not
saying they were all like that cuz I
know a lot of cool people that are in
[ __ ] AAA but like I really think that
if you're if you're an alcoholic that
when you're drinking your life just like
falls apart it really does you know what
I mean I mean I wake up hungover for
flights and it sucks and I definitely am
not a casual drinker I'm definitely a
[ __ ] binge drinker and I know that I
shouldn't be doing that [ __ ] but if I
actually had a real [ __ ] job that's
my biggest problem is I don't have a
[ __ ] job so like I have to tell you
like when you know when I'm like really
[ __ ] busy and I have [ __ ] to do I
don't really drink but the thing
like right now it's [ __ ] Tuesday it's
9:00 in the morning I'm sitting here in
my [ __ ] pajamas and I could just sit
here for the rest of the rest of the
goddamn week I don't have anything to do
I mean if I wasn't so [ __ ]
responsible patting myself on the back I
mean there's a bunch of [ __ ] that I
could just put off to next week and and
I could just sit here drinking non
[ __ ] stop so that's the problem my
problem is my [ __ ] free time so I'm
gonna respect the fact that you trying
to help me my wife my wife on the other
hand I've told her a bunch of times
saying am I an alcoholic she goes god
pill you're not an alcoholic you're not
a [ __ ] alcoholic so I would think
that she would know she lives with me
but I appreciate it
and all he's gonna say the whole time is
he's in denial he hasn't really the
beginning self you know what alcoholics
are like they're like Madonna you know
Madonna
I always just did over-the-top shocking
stuff you know what I mean and then if
you've been like Madonna that music
videos sucked and then they get to hide
behind well all I was looking for was a
reaction it's art art is just you know
you can't judge it so there you go
I don't know listen I'm open to the idea
if I am an alcoholic but there's no
[ __ ] way I'll ever be able to go to a
meeting there's no way I'm not gonna go
down there and just not [ __ ] laugh my
balls off listening to your [ __ ]
stories that would make Keith Richards
go Jesus Christ I know a guy that
[ __ ] he drank so much he did a
faceplant his [ __ ] teeth one of his
teeth [ __ ] went through his lower lip
alright and he woke up the next day with
his [ __ ] lips looking like a goddamn
duck bill any-any immediately grabbed
the [ __ ] you know a 40-ounce er they
put a straw in it
so he could keep drinking as the alcohol
most of it was going in his mouth part
of it was going through the hole that
was in his face as much as what more and
as I am I'd be like ah you know what I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] year off at this
point you know so whatever sir I
actually I think that there's different
degrees of abusing alcohol
I definitely abuse it admittedly I'm
wrong and it's definitely gotten out of
control but I'm like a habit guy like if
I'm working out I'm [ __ ] working out
like a maniac if I'm sitting around and
I'm eating bad food I eat bad food like
a [ __ ] maniac but not to the point of
like someone that has addiction like
I'll leave bad to the point I put on 15
20 pounds I don't have to be cut out of
my house
I don't balloon up a hundred [ __ ]
pounds the way somebody who's addicted
to food would alright and I'll go out
and I'll go on a [ __ ] booze binge and
be like I got to knock this off what the
[ __ ] am i doing I gotta knock this off
and I'm just kind of able to do it and I
feel like I have to apologize to you
that I'm able to do that I'm sorry I
mean look like I'm done right now like I
will have no problem going
I don't know as long as I [ __ ] want
to go you know it's not like I'm never
gonna have a glass of wine with a great
[ __ ] meal again but uh I don't know
whatever
I appreciate your your concern but I am
going to be sober now just out of vanity
because I got this new [ __ ] diet
right and the dean del rey was telling
me about and when i do that when i when
i'm on his diet and if i just go for a
[ __ ] walk around the block with my
lovely daughter i do that a couple times
a day and i'm not drinking and I'm not
eating sugar or anything like that I
barely have to work out and I
the [ __ ] the everything just falls
off you and it's the easiest way to stay
in shape and I [ __ ] hate working out
so that's way more appealing to me then
you know as much fun as I had over the
last [ __ ] week I mean it's way more
appealing at my age you know plus I got
a kit you know I got to have a kit and I
can't be like [ __ ] I just can't do it
I just can't do it I can't have it in my
[ __ ] life and that's it so I don't
need to go down there and do all of that
[ __ ] alright I'm a comedian all
right I don't like groups alright lady
who's bad at arguing dear Billy backward
balls backwards balls I'm actually a 15
year old girl oh Jesus
the [ __ ] whoo Andrew you trying to get
me in trouble here uh so I guess you
couldn't say really say that I'm a lady
oh my god this is already creeping me
out yet but I love your podcast and
listen to a 24/7 because I feel like
balanced needs no balance needs to be
restored to the world after all the
females listening to dr. Phil and loose
women have gotten a slightly [ __ ] up
view on things I respect that you're not
going to let mainstream media have the
only say on the truth in other words
what you're saying is you like to hear
my opinion I'm not always right but
you'll listen to it I appreciate that
all right my whole life the 15 years of
my life Jesus Christ
they [ __ ] my house set for 15 years I've
been meaning to get to it your whole
life is 15 years that's incredible my
whole life I've been bad at arguing
either I say the wrong thing at the
wrong time or I focus on the wrong point
or I am easily manipulated by guilt
trips etc whatever it is I can never get
it right or stand my ground for example
I have this one friend who is literally
three
I was a little a literal three-year-old
on the inside I thought you said you
went hanging out with a three-year-old I
was like this is getting even more
creepy I can't say [ __ ] to her without
her crying one time she wanted some of
my food but I told her that I hadn't had
breakfast and couldn't share that day
she said to me you're beat you're so
mean what the [ __ ] is your problem what
yeah you get that person out of your
life I just gave her some food because I
hate it when people think bad about me
but inside I was like [ __ ] what it took
me like two hours to realize that she
didn't even think I was me and she just
wanted the food and she knew how to get
it oh my god you know something your
thought process that it took me till I
was 37 to realize that you're way ahead
of the curve here what you're realizing
for the first time in real life is that
this people out there that are not good
people
see so what I did was I I went out into
the world where you are as a 15 year old
and existed as that person till about 37
before I actually started to examine
human behavior and yeah so what where
you are right now is when you first
start to realize that there's these cuts
in life what's gonna happen is like two
or three days later or an hour later
after the moment you're gonna be like oh
[ __ ] yeah she said blah blah blah blah
blah not cuz she meant that it's cuz she
wanted XY and Z well the more you do
that the more you're gonna be able to be
in the moment and you're gonna catch
people in the moment and then once
you're able to do it in real time people
aren't going to be able to [ __ ] with you
anymore
and then when and then the only thing
you'll have to learn how to do is the
judgment is this worth me you know
applying this skill in real time like
yesterday that guy who turned around
yelled [ __ ] you would bartnick and all
that there's like four of us one of him
over time Rosebowl not even worth
engaging we all just stared at him and
then he didn't know what to do he yelled
[ __ ] you and then he turned around and
he felt good he said [ __ ] you to four
guys we didn't do anything he feels good
and secure around his wife you know and
nobody got kicked out nobody had to
fight or whatever then there's other
times when you actually say something
back someone even I'll read the rest of
this but yep right out of the gate you
being too hard on yourself
right most of the girls in my class are
pretty weak physically and it happens to
be that as a girl I have unnaturally
broad shoulders excuse the pun and weigh
about two pounds more than most of them
the fact is hard to ignore when you're
staring at their [ __ ] face is while
their giggle behind their hands I have
violent tendencies which I'm working on
but I know I can beat the [ __ ] out of
them and that makes it so much harder to
verbally verbally argue they are much
better at it than me so even when I'm
right I lose and I always end up wanting
to just uppercut send an uppercut
straight to their [ __ ] skull whatever
all right I would love a few pointers as
to what to do in an argument and how to
tell them when I'm being manipulated
before I start latching on to the [ __ ]
up mind game of doing things some advice
would be great thanks a lot and go [ __ ]
yourself PS me and my sister have a huge
difference agreement because it's my
personal opinion that guys who have a
girlfriend should still be able to go to
strip clubs and have a good time without
their girlfriend getting mad my sister
says that for me to say that I must have
no respect for myself and we'll end up
with a piece-of-shit guy Jesus those are
two extreme opinions am i right or do I
have some sort of self-respect issues
that I'm not aware of yet all right let
me comment on the first [ __ ] thing
all right kids army kids bully they gang
up on you
you never should resort to physical
violence alright but what you got to do
is you got to fight fire with fire so
what you have to do alright is nobody's
perfect so you have to find that [ __ ]
thing
all right you have to find that [ __ ]
thing all right and you just get them
with that all right
and then they then it will hurt their
feelings especially if they're
good-looking popular people you can
really [ __ ] and get to him
all right like here's something that I
do that I learned to do after years of
arguing with people after my shows
you know if somebody came up to me he
was like hey let me tell you something
that stuff you said about with and
you're not [ __ ] Gaghan
and as they yelled all of that I used to
try to argue my points going well hey
you know it's just jokes
I also made fun of people in that
hurricane you didn't get offended by
that you know what I learned to do when
someone was given when they were giving
me [ __ ] I would just go hey hey you got
something between your teeth that's what
I would say even though they didn't and
then they would be so [ __ ] mortified
they'd walk away and then they'd be
going like you know you know sucking on
their teeth and [ __ ] and she should just
shut him the [ __ ] up so you need to find
your version of that okay so what I
would do is I would really study them
all right and what you got to do is you
just got to find something that's wrong
with them maybe their earlobes are too
big and I know this is very immature and
this is this is super [ __ ] mean and
that is an adult I shouldn't tell you to
do this because adults go with those
people they're not your real friends you
don't need to stoop to their level and
they give you all this [ __ ] butt
air-quote mature advice but you know
what that doesn't help you when you go
back into the [ __ ] the next day tell a
teacher
none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] works all
right because those [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
[ __ ] what terrible parents are gonna
find the time they're gonna find you so
that's what I would do all right there's
no way one of them doesn't have a
slightly crooked nose there's no way one
of them's titty isn't a little bit
bigger than the other or maybe their
nipples point down there's something
[ __ ] up about their chin if you know
up dick you got to fight fire with fire
if they're talking about you [ __ ]
shoulders all right first of all laugh
at it learn to laugh at yourself
all right they look at me I'm an old
friend headed [ __ ] okay and all of those
things should really end any dream that
I ever had in life but if you just roll
with it
if you steer into it and if I just be an
old bald redheaded [ __ ] then then what
can you do to me you just you gotta get
comfortable I would get more comfortable
with yourself alright and I'm sure your
shoulders are fine and all of that stuff
and when they make fun of your shoulders
laughs and then I would say yeah my
shoulders are as [ __ ] up as your
crooked titties or just you somehow you
laugh at your [ __ ] and then you [ __ ]
you get them you get them just tell them
you scored you once you know just tell
them they got bad breath you got any
some I don't just you'll find I wish you
know what you could add if you just
could have sent me a picture of him I
would have helped you out but then I
would have got in trouble because you're
teaching them to bully but blah blah
blah you know all of these people who
want to who want to fix problems with
five minutes on [ __ ] dr. Phil by the
way did I call it you see that big
scandal over there and I granted
innocent until proven guilty
old dr. Phil [ __ ] bringing the guests
up a notch there all right I punched a
girl whoa here's another one hey Bill
like your input on a situation I was
recently I was recently at a concert
some drunk skank accused me of stealing
her friend's phone I told you you got
the wrong guy
her and her [ __ ] her and her father
friend tried to wrestle my phone away
from me and I pushed them off then she
sucker-punched me in the eye big bruise
bloody eye and her friend snatched my
phone out of my pocket due to work that
came up and I told him what happened he
didn't seem to believe and was clearly
buddy-buddy with the girl so they go off
and were giggling around
giggling around I don't thought that
means after a few minutes I go up to a
to a fatso oh I go up to fatso and tell
her to give me my phone back she
realized it was mine and handed it over
as I went to walk away
skank number one in a douchebag
boyfriend accosted me again and grabbed
me I punched both them in the face and
then security escorted me out I think I
was justified to hit her in this case
what say you then go [ __ ] yourself uh
yeah I said I see I don't have a problem
with any of that I know a problem
someone gets physical with you you know
you take one punch to the eye you're all
of you physically [ __ ] up you didn't
do anything wrong some point you got to
defend yourself all right god bless you
I think he showed remarkable restraint
to only hit him both once that was an
easy one
no I won't even I wouldn't be even
concerned about it not at all and in
fact you probably made both of them
better people
hopefully probably not but you know if I
well you know when you get punched in
the face you know if you're an adult
some point you got to be looking at
yourself going like all right did I do
something there if you didn't then
you're like all right this person's an
[ __ ] and I need to have them out of
my life but you know if you did you
gotta be that guy that's kind of
shooting my mouth up there right that's
what I would do all right got two girls
pregnant help dude I can't help you
there's no help for this I buckled down
for the next [ __ ]
18 years all right hello bill I have a
big problem and I'm hoping that you and
the lovely Nia can help out with it all
right let me start by saying that I
don't live in a trailer or something I'm
a normal 26 year old guy I was dating
this girl we broke up a couple months
ago when we broke up a couple weeks
later I met this little hottie I started
hooking up with her and then I got a
call a couple weeks ago my ex is three
months pregnant with my child and she's
keeping it I then broke things off with
the hottie well guess what I knocked her
up too
buddy did you ever take a health class
do you know how to [ __ ] help people
get pregnant neither one knows the other
is pregnant and I have no idea what to
do I broke things off with the hottie to
work on being there for my ex and the
kid I want to be there for her and help
her out with all the prenatal stuff and
be a great dad now it seems my life is
not going to be that way the other girl
once they had the baby too I use
protection with this girl but not enough
I guess well what does that mean dude if
you use a condom I would get him
eternity first of all I would make both
of them subject to it okay because you
broke up for a couple of months right
get a maternity test times two
do not give either one of them a [ __ ]
dime or else you know in some states the
second you start paying that kid is
yours that's the first thing I would do
first thing I would do was tell both of
them your situation the second thing I
get will make Malta both of them get a
[ __ ] is it a maternity test a paternity
test
I said maternity paternity tests they go
the other girl wants to have a baby too
blah blah blah my ex was on birth
control yet I still knocked her up if I
had to be with one of them it would be
the new girl because she is hotter I'm a
pig sue me and we also like a lot of the
same things what should I do
I'm so sick and exhausted of worrying
about this I just want to do the right
things thank you and go [ __ ] yourself
well I would tell both of them what's
going on I would get a paternity test
not a maternity test get a paternity
test and make sure those are your kids
and I would if you want to be with the
hottie be with the hottie there you go
and then I would stay in the life for
the other one that's what I would do and
I would [ __ ] get a vasectomy or cut
up a garden hose because whatever the
[ __ ] you're using is not working all
right
that's the podcast oh it's a long one
hour and 20 minutes here Happy New Year
at everybody good luck to you I
apologize to anybody in a
whatever the [ __ ] it is and that's it
I'm sipping my tea I'm gonna go eat
healthy all right and I will go back to
booze at some point if I [ __ ] want to
because I don't think all right that's
it
I'll check in on you on Thursday